on the surface it looks like apple is
having a pretty good year
after all it did become the world's most
valuable publicly traded company
but behind the scenes its long-standing
disputes with app developers
are bubbling over into public view apple
is facing
stiff backlash over the way it runs the
app store at a time when the app store
is
a key part of its business cue
the fortnite gaming controversy
over the summer epic games publicly
rebelled against the app store's 30
fees and urged players to join its fight
against
apple ladies and gentlemen apple just
banned fortnite
what it's going down apple
versus fortnite they're probably the one
company out there right now that is so
beloved by
the the public that they'll be able to
at least you know put up the best fight
it's not just epic games
spotify airbnb tinder facebook and
netflix
have all had disputes with apple over
app store rules
all while lawmakers are scrutinizing
apple and other tech companies for
potential anti-trust
violations what's to stop apple from
increasing
its commission to 50 we sir
we have never increased commissions in
the store since the first day it
operated in 2008
so what are app makers asking for and
is apple going to listen first
it's important to understand how crucial
the app store has become to apple's
business
in recent years apple's been shifting
its focus from selling more devices like
iphones
to selling more software and services
think apple music
applecare and of course the app store
apple one gives you
and your family all the services you
love in one
simple plan in 2020 its services
business
which includes the app store helped the
company set a new sales record in the
june quarter
apple doesn't break out its app store
revenue but analysts estimate
it brought in roughly 17.5 billion
dollars for fiscal year 2020.
some apps and services are particularly
important for the app store ecosystem
like fortnite the game has more than 100
million registered users on apple
devices
that's produced more than a billion
dollars in global app store spending
since its launch in 2018 but in august
fortnite was kicked off the app store
altogether that's because the game's
creator
epic games set up a system to get money
directly from players without paying
apple it's cut
apple takes a 30 commission on sales of
apps and
in-app purchases so if an app costs 4.99
up front apple collects a dollar fifty
while the app creator gets the rest
same goes for if you use an app to buy
digital goods like virtual weapons
or sign up for a subscription to a
monthly service
but the fee doesn't apply to physical
goods and services like clothing
purchases or
home rentals what epic games did was
it tried to skirt that commission by
adding its own payment system
to the fortnite app on iphones and ipads
that goes against apple's rules
apple pulled fortnite from the app store
epic sued apple
and then apple filed a counter suit
google pulled fortnite from google play
in august for the same reason
and since the two companies banned the
app their monthly revenue from the game
has taken a big hit
from a developer perspective it
definitely feels like we're
forced to pay 30 right off the top
austin benson developed an app for apple
and android called hang
that helped organize meetups and he's
currently a cto
at a small tech startup it literally
feels like a tax and those dollars don't
really go towards
a government to pay roads and bridges
they go to pay
two of the biggest and arguably most
powerful corporations in the world
in late september spotify the owner of
tinder
and epic games teamed up to pressure
apple and other app store operators to
change their rules
apple and google have defended their
business practices
saying the commission fees are necessary
because of the services the stores
provide
including security and safeguarding user
privacy
in some cases the battle over app store
fees
has also spilled over into accusations
of apple allegedly stifling
competition enter spotify's fight with
apple
in 2019 spotify filed a formal complaint
to the eu
accusing apple of making it difficult
for rivals of apple music
to promote their subscription services
without using apple's payment system
apple takes a 30 cut on subscriptions
for the first year
and 15 the second year if you were to
upgrade to premium in our app
through the app store we'd have to give
apple a whopping 30
of your subscription fee spotify didn't
want to pay that fee on its premium
subscription revenue
so it removed the option to sign up from
within the app
users can still register on spotify's
website but apple's rules don't allow
spotify to direct users from the app
to its site netflix has taken a similar
approach
telling users you can't sign up for
netflix in the app and
tinder charges members more to sign up
in the app compared to its website
apple said that developers are free to
promote other pricing outside of the app
store
including on television and billboards
certainly when you see the big
heavyweight companies like netflix and
spotify make that move
you can imagine that uh other companies
are considering the same thing
uh but if you look at a netflix and a
spotify they're in a better position in
the market themselves so they could
potentially do a
say a tv commercial that says sign up
here um smaller companies may not have
that ability
apple has said it doesn't give its own
products an advantage and that its 30
fee is in line with the rest of the
industry but
if you're an app developer your business
largely depends on just two companies
apple and google roughly 95
of all mobile apps spending in the us
happens on the app store and google play
we have congress the department of
justice the european union
the the ftc they're all investigating
apple um
and other technology giants too on
antitrust grounds uh
google and amazon and facebook they're
under the spotlight as well
the attention though with apple by these
government entities though has so far
centered largely around the app store
and the app store has become essentially
apple's bread and butter
in late september apple said it would
exempt some apps from paying commissions
on virtual events hosted during the
pandemic
but many app makers say they want apple
to review its commission policies
altogether
and apple's legal battles aren't going
away anytime
soon depending on how things play out
the fortnite case
could have a lasting impact on how much
revenue developers are able to keep
and how apps accept payments altogether
the
biggest thing that i'm watching on the
sidelines
is is apple going to continue to take 30
because that is just a large number off
the top which means i have that much
less
to higher sales and marketing teams hire
other developers and get my product out
to other people and it makes it that
much harder as a small business to
survive
there are all sorts of possibilities as
to what could happen or things could say
the status quo
um but given the importance of the app
store to
apple's bottom line should the outcome
be
such changes that could have a serious
effect on
apple's finances
you